health and health system indicators
including covet 19 positive
hospitalizations and icu patients
and the number of outbreaks in long-term
care and hospitals continues to decline
as does the number of active resident
cases in long-term care
the percent positivity of tests has
remained stable this week at 12.4
percent and most of the wastewater sites
across the province are reporting either
stable or a downward trend
while overall we have seen improvement
there is some regional variation
primarily in the north part of the
province
we will continue to monitor this
situation closely in our and provide our
assistance and support as needed
once again i want to thank ontarians for
their incredible sacrifices these
collective efforts have allowed us to
get to where we are today
on tuesday march 1st we intend to
continue our cautious phased and staged
reopening of the province by lifting
capacity limits in all remaining indoor
public settings
and proof of vaccination will no longer
be required from patrons in certain
businesses
as we proceed with the reopening of the
province it is important to note that
this virus is still with us and will
remain with us for some time
covet 19 remains a global challenge
but we know what works we have tools
that we did not have just two years ago
including highly effective vaccines that
have changed the course of the pandemic
high vaccination rates that continue to
improve as more and more ontarians see
the value of getting boosted to protect
themselves their families and their
communities
ever increasing supplies of effective
treatments for those at risk of getting
very sick treatments that mitigate the
risk of severe outcomes of covet 19 and
significantly reduce the risk of
hospitalization
two years of experience on how to best
protect vulnerable settings such as
retirement homes long-term care homes as
well as how to mitigate spread in school
and other education settings
we will continue to closely monitor for
new variants
that may bring new challenge
challenges and will we will use the
knowledge and experience we have
on how this virus behaves and what works
to stop its transmission
masking requirements will remain in
place for the time being but we are
reviewing these measures and hope to
provide an update in the coming weeks
masking does remain an important tool in
our toolbox and even when it's no longer
required in public settings it will
continue to be an effective tool
for reducing transmission and protecting
those recovering from illness their
close contacts and those who may be more
vulnerable to severe covet 19 infection
some in our communities may also choose
to continue wearing them regularly and
we need to be respectful of individual
choices once masking is no longer
required
given the positive trends in the public
health indicators and the high
vaccination rate we are
actively reviewing all directives and
instructions to health care providers or
organizations that were temporarily put
in place in response to the covet 19
pandemic
itandani
the eventual lifting of these directives
and instructions reflects a move toward
regular operations
that will continue to ensure staff
students clients residents and patients
are protected
keeping these important groups safe will
be
in part done through recommendations and
guidance from my office including for
prevention infection prevention and
control
i know that i signaled my hope that we
may be able to do so by march 1st in
alignment with the next steps of the
province's reopening but it may take a
little longer as we continue to work
with the relevant sectors to ensure that
there are no gaps in guidance as we look
to lift these measures in the near
future rest assured this work is
underway and will be communicated with
sector partners and the public when it's
ready
vaccination has been a key component of
our coven 19 response and continues to
be the most effective tool to reduce the
risk of hospitalization and death it is
important that health care workers
get their first second and third doses
doses if they have not already done so
in the face of the omicron threat we are
fortunate that our vaccination rollout
continues to be strong and as of
february 23rd
85.2 percent of ontario's total
population has received at least one
dose 81.3 percent have received two
doses and 47 percent have received three
doses
especially pleased to see that we
expanded eligibility youth on february
18th
and 6.2 percent of those 12 to 17 year
olds have come forward to get their
booster doses
boosters in our are an effective means
of reducing your likelihood of becoming
seriously ill from covet 19 and there's
good evidence that vaccination cuts your
risk of developing long covid syndrome
in half
dosto
yen
even if you have had coveted in the past
getting vaccinated is still recommended
as it provides better protection against
future infection once again i want to
thank ontarians
for their incredible sacrifices while
the risk remains and we must remain
nimble in our response and be ready to
respond to these new risks it is clear
they were coming out of this wave of
omicron and that the coming months as we
move into spring and summer will provide
some needed relief thank you merci
we'll go to the phone lines for
questions just a reminder it's one
question one follow-up over to the first
question please
from anthony artusso the toronto sun
good afternoon dr moore are you likely
to remove all masking orders at the same
time or do you anticipate phasing them
out and if so where would school
children be on that timetable
so the consultations have started and we
will be working with school boards with
parents with the ministries
and make a decision together but we do
anticipate if we remove it in the public
sector we would do it simultaneously for
the schools that would seem to align as
the risk decreases to do them together
follow up
antenna
sorry um do you have any recommendations
for march break is it okay to go away
now
so certainly the federal government uh
continues to advise
ontarians that there is an ongoing risk
but that miss can be that risk can be
mitigated by taking appropriate
precautions by having been vaccinated by
testing upon return
and following
masking distancing in the environment
where you're going to be traveling to so
i think the risk is decreasing day by
day i think any family should do a risk
assessment of where they're going to
what the risk of the virus is in in that
setting
and certainly take into consideration if
they've got any underlying medical
illnesses
and potentially consult with their
health care provider if they do
but otherwise the risk has been
decreasing
week by week across north america and i
would
encourage ontarians if they've taken
advantage of immunization and follow the
basic principles to to enjoy march break
as best they can
next question
from allison jones at the canadian press
hi dr moore um i'm wondering if among
all of these things that you're
reviewing i wonder if isolation rules
are
included in that are you looking at
changing or rescinding all of the rules
that were brought in at the height of
the omicron wave
in terms of you know what symptomatic
people have to do what people have to do
if someone in their household has
symptoms for example
yeah thank you very much allison that is
absolutely on our agenda we want to
review
those requirements at present
and ensure that they reflect the risk
and are balanced and proportionate to
the risk we know and thank so many
ontarians that have stayed home once
they've been a high-risk contact or once
they've had the disease so they've
minimized the spread
but in light of high vaccination rates
effective therapeutics
and the diminishing risk week by week
across ontario all of those protocols
have to be reviewed so
our team is actively consulting with
local public health agencies with public
health ontario which provides scientific
guidance to us uh on how we can
cautiously slowly
remove
any isolation or quarantine requirements
but it has to be
proportionate to the risk
and when we're in a safer safer time
frame
follow-up
yeah thank you um you've said uh that
you wanted to end workplace vaccine
policies um so it might take a little
bit longer than march first but
um the long-term care minister says the
vaccine mandate for workers in that
sector is being reviewed i know you said
you previous i know you previously said
that you don't have the power to revoke
that one but in your opinion as the
province is top doctor do you think that
that mandate should stay in place for a
while longer given how vulnerable that
population is
we'll have to celebrate how well we've
done in the long-term care sector both
from an immunization rate for the
patients or clients
that that live in in that environment um
we were one of the first to have a third
dose strategy in august of 2022 uh one
of the first in north america to have a
fourth dose strategy for clients in in
that environment uh and the workers have
stepped up they've gotten their first
second uh and a vast majority have
gotten their third dose so at this point
i'm absolutely supportive of working
with the minister to reflect uh on their
current rate of vaccination
and the risk in the community and
review whether that mandate
of a third dose in workers should be
maintained
next question
from charlie pinkerton at queen's park
briefing
hi dr moore um my first question is
about uh some well newer vaccines
against coca-19 and newer to us here in
canada
that of novobacks and metacagos which i
believe uh the latter of which was
approved today
um a couple months ago you were speaking
about novavax's vaccine
and you shared an opinion with other
experts i've heard that because of the
technology it's based on it's a more uh
i guess familiar vaccine to some people
unlike those of which are based on mrna
technology
um
do you or or do you think the province
should reach out to the federal
government to try to acquire doses of
these vaccines um or
as ontario's sort of gotten as far
as it will
in terms of its effort to vaccinate as
many people as possible with vaccines
that's already received
oh thanks so much tony so we're actually
very excited about both uh novovax and
the medicago uh products they are uh
proving to be highly safe highly
effective uh they are more of a
traditional vaccine and that may have
appealed to
the 10 percent or so of 12 plus
population that haven't received a
vaccine as of yet um so we we are
working with the federal government to
get
i would believe medi novovax will be the
first product available it should be
available second or third week of march
in ontario and we'll communicate that
directly to all ontarians i hope that
the 10 percent of ontarians
adults 12 and up would reflect and
review this product with their health
care provider and see if it's right for
them
it is
highly effective against multiple
strains of of kovid including omicron
and we think it will be available in
significant amounts the second and third
week of march
the medicago product
we have heard just recently that its
delivery to ontarians may be delayed
several months
so we we may not hear of its
availability uh uh confirmed until maybe
may or june so of all the products
available novovax to me is still
exciting uh it's a traditional vaccine
where
the protein the recombinant protein is
being injected that's how most other
vaccines work like influenza
you'll build antibodies against it and
then your immunity both cell based and
antibody based will
continue its two-dose
vaccine at present
and it's um i think it's a great
alternative for those that didn't want
an mrna vaccine
that it is more of a traditional
technology and i hope it does appeal to
some uh who have yet uh taken advantage
of our vaccination strategy
follow-up
okay great thanks um thanks for that sir
i'll answer um
once the health ministry directive
regarding vaccination policies for
hospital employees
is lifted
this is going to be your advice
that it would be a greater benefit for
hospitals to re-hire nurses who lost
their jobs because they didn't meet
their hospitals vaccination policy
or
you know would it be
better for these nurses to not be
rehired because of the additional risk
that they would still continue to pose
so thanks for that question i i just
have to be clear
directives from the cmh office are are
meant to be time limited
and they
are to be an immediate risk to the
health of the population
and so we we are
forced to review any directive that's in
place given that um we're we're at a
different phase of the pandemic and the
risk is decreasing day by day so uh it
it
it is always necessary for me to review
all directors that are written by the
chief medical officer of health um
so i i don't want anyone listening to
say i i don't endorse immunization of
health care workers or policies to
immunize healthcare workers
what we're asking now is if if the
directive has to be removed we're asking
all of our healthcare partners to
reflect on their current policies
i would suggest they do adopt an
immunization policy for new hires uh
especially uh and or for those that were
let go and that the corporations that
have let any individuals go have to
reflect on their policies but we won't
be prescriptive in any way
i absolutely a hundred percent endorse
anyone providing care to a vulnerable
member of our community to be immunized
last question unless someone else joins
the queue
from jeff gray at the globe in mail
oh hi thanks i just want to ask about
the mask policies
that you're that you're looking at
lifting you mentioned lifting them all
simultaneously is the goal but
would there still be hold over mask
mandates or masked policies
for say hospitals or long-term care or
maybe even public transit is that
something you'd consider thanks very
much jeff i i would absolutely
want to reflect that high-risk settings
such as public transit
such as hospitals and long-term care
would maintain a masking policy
beyond when we appeal it
for general indoor settings
for ontarians so the highest risk
settings i think we've learned
that the mass have benefit they reduce
the risk of spread of of multiple
different pathogens not just covid
and have provided a safety net that is
necessary in those high-risk settings to
so many vulnerable
patients and populations so um we we
will be reflecting on where we would
maintain them uh and i think you're
right at the highest risk settings we
would want to maintain them but always
reviewing the policy
over time
and
eliminate them in more general public
settings
eliminate the the mandatory nature of
them
we're doing ongoing jurisdictional scans
of
lessons learned so we're looking at
england where they're maintaining it in
in public transit uh on the tube in
london for example uh and they're
maintaining it in their long-term care
settings in acute care settings so
we're trying to learn best practices
globally and provincially
and
as the risk decreases in ontario make
recommendations to government with that
in mind
follow-up
thanks for that and going back to your
comments uh off the top about um
wastewater
uh you know declining the the signal the
the amount of coverage we're finding in
wastewater declining or stable
are you still seeing those increases uh
or worrying levels in
certain
public health units or certain areas of
the province of northern ontario are we
still seeing a rise there or those
tailing off as well yeah in particular
in the northeast we're seeing a rise
and
we're
seeing stabilization
in some of the wastewater settings
across ontario uh and and i'm learning
through that surveillance system they
can break it down by water treatment
plant even within a city so uh in in
toronto for example
you could see an ongoing risk in certain
neighborhoods uh in the north of toronto
so uh at present the highest risk areas
where we're seeing
an ongoing
rise in in wastewater surveillance is
mainly the northeast but there are
pockets uh within cities and or within
uh
communities
where we're seeing ongoing risks so
even though and this is an important
message jeff even though we're reducing
capacity limits in certain settings and
opening the economy
the risk does remain
we will see ongoing transmission and the
waste water is a reflection of that
ongoing risk of transmission it's not
down to zero in any community in ontario
but the rates are stabilizing and our
health system is stabilizing and has
capacity to care for people who get ill
from omicron
but the risk remains so please continue
wear your mask
wash your hands
come forward to get your first second
third or fourth doses of vaccine
because
it's it's not gone yet
last question
from rob ferguson at the toronto star
hi doctor just wanted to clarify or make
sure i understand what you said earlier
about
when you're asked about masking in
schools you said you would look to
remove the masking in the public sector
and schools in the same time and i
wasn't quite sure how extensive you
meant to be by saying public sector
could you just give us a little bit more
detail on that yeah so in i i meant
indoor
uh indoor public settings uh outdoors uh
with uh appropriate distancing uh i
wouldn't
make
any mandatory recommendation on masking
but indoor public settings depending
upon how
many people are in a setting we
we will be reviewing
the recommendation i'm asking in that
environment
and the general feedback from the
community members that we've
sought feedback from at present
is if if you're going to lift them in
recreational facilities
and in other indoor facilities it just
makes sense to also do it simultaneously
for educational sector
follow-up and this is the last question
okay understood thank you very much for
that and i'm wondering given your
answers to jeff there just a minute ago
about
excuse me about the
the wastewater indicators
um
given it's taking place in certain
pockets in northeastern ontario certain
pockets of cities
who is still getting covet at this point
is it healthcare workers can you just
pin it down a little bit for us and
on what the most risky kind of
situations are who knows i just want to
confirm that we're staying seeing
ongoing spread at a community level uh
and across all age groups uh it can from
the pcr testing it remains uh that 20 to
40 year old age group it appears to have
higher rates but it's a biased sample
who gets access to to pcr
from a hospitalization vantage point
it's the older age groups that are
having higher rates of hospitalization
and that's been consistent across the
pandemic you know if 50 to 60 60 to 70
the age group risk increases and that's
why it comforts me so much that uh you
know 86 percent of those over 70 have
gotten their third doses uh if we can i
i would uh absolutely endorse more
ontarians coming forward for their third
dose especially if you've got any under
crop under any underlying chronic
illness any risk that would predispose
you to hospitalization for covet 19
please come forward
and continue to get your dose because
the risk is still there in communities
the virus is still present
it's just that the impact on the health
care system has stabilized
thanks everyone